et à monsieur frédéric trahissent
président mon nas à cette question
madame la vie naïve de l'éducation
nationale la réforme du collège ne passe
pas
actuellement les enseignants vivent une
année particulièrement difficile et
subissent bon gré mal gré par vagues
successives des formations pour entrer
dans une ère nouvelle celle de la
suppression des classes bilangues celle
de la mort annoncée du latin celle du
déclin de l'allemand celle de
l'avènement des enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire les enseignants
déplorent le caractère liberticide de
l'éducation nationale et rejette
massivement cette réforme qui amputent
les enseignements disciplinaires et
dégradent leurs conditions de travail
lors des épi
des élèves regroupés face à une
situation non scolaires devront faire
des maths de l'anglais ou du français et
du groupe et des règles d'orthographe en
situation interdisciplinaire et coachée
par un professeur les élèves construire
ont eux mêmes leur savoir la belle
affaire
ce n'est pas la bonne méthode ni pour
restaurer l'autorité des enseignants ni
pour donner confiance aux élèves en
difficulté et quelle idée saugrenue de
vouloir faire de l'aide personnalisée
par classe entière pour faire réussir
chaque élève on a besoin de lui donner
un cadre sécurisant avec des horaires
fixes et non des emplois du temps à
géométrie variable
dorénavant de la 5e à la 3e les
changements intempestifs qui devront au
jeu site adapté les moyens aux
dispositions locales déstabiliseront les
familles de plus en plus tentés par
l'enseignement privé au québec
le renouveau pédagogique une politique
éducative qui ressemble à s'y méprendre
à cette réforme a abouti à un échec
retentissant après dix ans les résultats
sont en baisse et les inégalités en
hausse
c'est malheureusement ce qui nous attend
quand comptez vous arrêtez cette réforme
inique merci monsieur rice la parole et
à madame najat vallaud belkacem ministre
de l'éducation nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
reiss
cela faisait longtemps tout ce temps qui
a passé entre la dernière polémique au
sujet de la réforme du collège et votre
question d'aujourd'hui a permis aux
équipes pédagogiques sur le terrain
sereinement de travailler sur la
préparation de la rentrée prochaine donc
si ça peut répondre à vos inquiétudes et
vous rassurer car je sens beaucoup
d'inquiétude en vous je vous dirais que
les choses se passent bien
oui dans les étables et s'il vous plaît
cela intéressera les parents des
collégiens et des futurs collégiens dans
les établissements scolaires on prépare
la rentrée 2016 avec quatre mille
nouveaux postes d'enseignants ça n'est
pas rien ces quatre mille nouveaux
postes d'enseignants vont permettre en
effet d'avoir de l'accompagnement
personnalisé pour les élèves notamment
de sixième concrètement un élève de
sixième qui arrive de l'école primaire
qui n'est pas préparée à la vie en
collège aura désormais trois heures par
semaine d'accompagnement personnalisé on
l'aidera à rattraper ses difficultés à
avancer à ne pas creuser son retard oui
les enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire ce nouveau type
d'enseignement qui consiste à faire
travailler les élèves pas simplement
dans l'étude passive mais aussi dans le
travail collectif autour de projets qui
développe notamment leurs capacités
orale ses enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire sont en train de se
préparer avec des heures supplémentaires
que nous avons donnée aux établissements
chef d'établissement qui les
répartissent entre les disciplines
aucune discipline l'elysée contrairement
à ce que vous n'êtes de répéter pour la
150e fois mais c'est pas parce qu'on dit
150 fois les choses qu'elle devienne
utile que vous répondre une troisième
chose peut-être oui à partir de la
rentrée prochaine les collégiens
apprendrons plus tôt allez allez
s'il vous plaît que chacun retrouve son
calme hollande vivante très tôt c'est
une compétence indispensable pour les
enfants
quand monsieur reich je vous le dirai
aussi simplement que je le pense cette
réforme du collège qui a été pensée d'un
élève elle surfait dans leur intérêt et
ce sera une réussite merci la parole est
à monsieur pat